parce que tu as été fier parce qu'elle
un jour peut-être le fils d'un roulant
ou d'un cheminot
[Musique]
non ça m'est jamais arrivé
si j'avais dû faire un autre métier
non je suis à ma place
s'il y a des fois je les ai accepté tant
pis
un départ c'est toujours quelque chose
moi ça me plaît bien même si je suis pas
sur la machine même si je suis pas
conducteur l'ambiance de la gare me
plaît c'est vrai
si c'est le reflet de toute la société
c'est ça qui est intéressant et les
pauvres il y a les riches il y a ceux
qui rit à ceux qui pleurent
il y a ceux qui arrivent trop tard en
train de partir
je les regarde vivre
j'aime bien j'aime bien la gare
les voyageurs par rapport au train
je lui propose
il y a l'aspect poétique il existait
peut-être davantage autant de la vapeur
mais il y a l'aspect poétique qui a pu
inspirer certaines personnes c'est vrai
on va la mettre la bête humaine la bête
humaine c'est un c'est un beau roman
d'Émile Zola
Robert fournigaud 46 ans l'un des 20000
agents de conduite de la SNCF l'un des
80 conducteurs à pouvoir conduire des
express à 200 km/h derrière lui 31 ans
de carrière au chemin de fer
alors on fait exactement alors
ça pose des problèmes particuliers de
rouler à 200 à l'heure
oui
bien sûr
je suis un peu dans les conditions nous
sommes visibilité est mauvaise
Minecraft
tous les arbres
c'est pas un peu lassant la langue de
faire toujours le même trajet non
il y a aucun train qui se ressemble
qui a toujours quelque chose qui se
passe il y a toujours quelque chose de
nouveau il y a toujours une part
d'imprévu qui fait que ce métier là on
circule sur la même ligne c'est vrai je
circule sur la même ligne
paysage si vous voulez le paysage je ne
vois pas le paysage voilà
si exceptionnel
le film je le connais je le connais trop
par cœur
[Musique]
du tout
faire un train en plein mois de juillet
en plein jour quand tout va bien et puis
faire le même train quand il fait moins
10 qui chez elle qui a du givre que vous
risquez d'arracher les pantographes vous
risquez un tas de choses alors là ça
change
je pourrais raconter autant d'histoires
que j'ai fait de train c'est pratique
c'est vrai
500000 cheminots à la fin de la guerre
280000 aujourd'hui pour entretenir
surveiller et rouler sur le plus long
réseau d'Europe 36000 km de bois
en 1971 pour la première fois la route a
dépassé le fer dans le transport des
marchandises mais la crise de l'énergie
peut demain tout remettre en cause
plus que jamais le chemin de fer est
vivant
[Musique]
le service marchandise Robert fournigaud
le connaît bien et c'est là comme tous
les conducteurs qu'il a débuté mais pour
lui ce travail est devenu aujourd'hui
moins fréquent
seul sur la plupart des trains de
voyageurs les conducteurs sont cependant
toujours deux sur les trains de
marchandises et les Express dépassant
160 km heure
minorité dans la grande famille des
cheminots les roulants sont longtemps
restés les aristocrates du rail face au
sédentaires qui ne monteront jamais sur
une locomotive et dans les salaires sont
généralement bien à faire
aujourd'hui cependant le conducteur
électricien n'a plus le prestige ni le
pouvoir d'achat des mécaniciens
d'autrefois ceux du service vapeur
qu'est-ce que c'est que le salaire d'un
conducteur
[Musique]
c'est un traitement nous avons un
traitement comme tous les cheminots qui
est variable suivant le niveau
d'ancienneté
et puis à ce traitement il faut ajouter
une prime
qui s'appelle une prime de traction
[Musique]
et qui tient compte de deux éléments
importants
qui sont les kilomètres parcourus dans
le mois
et la catégorie des trains remarqué
rapide EXPRESS marchandises
et ces deux éléments font que nous avons
des salaires différents
cette différence est relativement
importante puisque combien et bien
écoutez entre deux conducteurs on peut
trouver une différence
mensuelle de 1000 francs et même
davantage dans certains cas c'est quand
même important alors ce qui vous
concerne combien est-ce que vous gagnez
mais écoutez mon salaire se situe
traitement plus prime entre 3000 et 3230
par mois
ça vous paraît peut-être un peu tôt mais
bon pas à moi
enfin c'est particulier au roulant ou
c'était tendu à tous les cheminots non
c'est parti le service de route les gens
au service de route sont toujours partis
à 50 ans
j'estime que c'est une bonne limite
de plus en plus vite et
oui les problèmes de santé aussi
le bruit
on peut pas voir sur un train il faut
faire ça pendant 25 ans au bout de 25
ans on s'aperçoit de certains troubles
Louis par exemple
le bruit nous fatigue énormément moi je
vois quand je rentre à la maison si les
gosses
font de la musique vous savez la musique
maintenant c'est très fort ça me fatigue
non j'en ai assez sur les machines
parce que votre femme travaille non non
elle a travaillé
pendant deux ans trois ans enfin on
n'avait pas d'enfant à ce moment-là mais
dès qu'on a eu des enfants
à la saison de travail vous avez combien
d'enfants
quel âge
a 19 ans il va avoir 20 ans maintenant
et Pascal 17 ans
que font-ils vos enfants
tous les deux en classe Lionel était à
la faculté de sciences à Saint-Denis
et Pascal est au lycée au lycée du
Raincy
alors sur un seul salaire sur 3000
francs nouveau par mois
[Musique]
il y a des sacrifices à faire
il faut se mettre au diapason
je croyais que j'avais perdu en fin de
compte
quand même
souvent que vous vous retrouviez en
famille pour dîner comme ce soir
c'est
oh ça arrive bien sûr mais enfin
il arrive bien qu'à tout ça un jour
quand même tous les quatre prévenez
comme ça
c'est pas souvent quoi vous passez plus
de temps dans les trains que en famille
j'ai l'impression que je passe une bonne
partie de mon temps dans les trains
c'est vrai
donc vos horaires votre emploi du temps
ça ne correspond pas toujours aux
horaires de la famille de vos fils du
tout du tout
du tout on a pas une vie comme tout le
monde
si je pars prendre mon service à 11h du
matin je peux pas être là avec mes
enfants et ma femme pour manger
un peu spéciale oui combien vous êtes
toujours de repos aujourd'hui maintenant
on a 93 repos par an depuis quand
depuis 1969 ça c'est amélioré petit à
petit à partir de 1969
vous avez fait pour obtenir des jours de
repos
oui il y a eu il y a eu les événements
de 68
mais il y a eu surtout de grève c'est
exact en 69
degrés des agents de conduite au mois de
mars et au mois de septembre
qui ont été déterminés
moi personnellement ce que je pense
c'est que il y a aucun cheminot qui soit
sédentaire à l'atelier ou dans le triage
qui soit mieux le dit que le conducteur
au contraire je pense que les caméras
qui sont laquelle dans les triages et
bien ils sont moins bien notés que nous
pour nous agents de conduite suite à
l'insuffisance des résultats
la grève un côté désagréable justement
pour ceux qui ont subi les conséquences
et enfin le public manque aussi
l'information et ne comprend pas
toujours les motifs exact de la grève
pendant la grève est parfois nécessaire
puis toute façon on sait jamais de
gaieté de cœur qu'on fait grève c'est
toujours quand il y a plus rien à faire
nous avons des revendications qui
traînent depuis des années et des années
qui le chemin de fer c'est une grande
entreprise
et la direction est certainement très
près de ceux qui gouvernent et qui ont
la charge de nous diriger et ils sont
loin de nos problèmes vous sont très
loin très loin de nous il me semble on a
eu la satisfaction de nombreuses fois
d'être unis à chaque fois à chaque fois
ça a été payant il y a des cheminots qui
ont des salaires bien inférieurs au mien
et je sais que pour eux c'est très dur
de quoi la SNCF portera la
responsabilité d'un rebondissement et
d'une gravation du conflit
on verra ça à février
on va bien qu'elle revienne quand même
Jacques Vial son beau-frère est entré le
même jour à la SNCF et travail dans le
même dépôt il leur arrive de se
retrouver sur la même machine
bizarre heureusement que oui c'est drôle
oui quand on est à deux sur un train où
il y a énormément de de zone à 200 km à
l'heure il faut agir très très
rapidement tout est fonction de la
vitesse et
notre attention est absolument
de tous les instants
à quelle heure est-ce que vous avez
quitté votre maison ce matin moi j'ai
pas eu le 35 à 20h quoi 5 heures
je suis parti de la maison à 5h15
pour prendre le premier métro et à
quelle heure vous comptez rentrer chez
vous ce soir
une heure et demie
une heure et demie deux heures moins le
quart 1h45
et demain matin donc on est à quelle
heure
demain matin
on travaille pas le matin là
les horaires des trains de la SNCF voilà
exactement
est-ce que ça pose des problèmes sur le
plan de votre santé les gens voilà
certainement oui certainement
[Musique]
le sommeil surtout le sommeil le sommeil
est pas mal dormir sur commande il
faudrait dormir quand on en a pas envie
et quand comme aujourd'hui vous avez 9
heures à passer à Limoges qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez bien faire on va se reposer
il a fallu un repos exceptionnel à
Limoges ou j'avais le temps de tout
faire j'avais le temps aussi les mains
et j'avais le temps de me reposer alors
c'était exceptionnel et le film que vous
avez choisi
le chemin de fer
[Musique]
on pense choisir comme il faut avant et
puis après
on se rend compte
de la vie vous montre si vous avez fait
un choix qui est bon qui est mauvais en
l'occurrence pour moi j'ai eu la chance
qu'il soit pas bon
[Musique]
parce que vous ne regrettez pas de temps
en temps de ne pas rester chez vous tout
le temps
je
regarde pas parce que
si j'avais dû faire un autre métier je
fais ma place
s'il y a des fois
c'est une vie spéciale mais enfin
c'était de vous n'avez jamais eu l'envie
d'abandonner par exemple
non
pour des cons quelconque je pouvais plus
faire mon métier là je sens que j'en
souffrirai c'est sûr j'ai toujours envie
de faire comme les gens qui roulaient
envie de partir
c'est pas l'envie de partir c'est
l'envie de
j'ai envie de faire des trains
un peu l'impression d'avoir sacrifié
votre vie de famille à votre vocation à
votre métier à l'amour du chemin de fer
non je pense pas j'ai une bonne vie de
famille
ça s'est bien passé pour moi vous
comprenez
ça s'est bien passé ça se passe pas bien
pour tout le monde c'est vrai
mais
ouais très heureux quand même
parce qu'on n'a pas l'impression d'avoir
un peu imposé votre vie de famille cette
vie de famille à votre femme
vous n'avez pas regretté un jour
mais l'imposer
quand on s'est marié tu savais bien que
j'allais rouler quand même non
je savais bien mais est-ce que vous
imaginez cette vie
je me suis mariée et j'ai pas imaginé la
vie qu'on aurait par son travail
d'ailleurs je travaillais aussi
alors je me suis mariée c'est tout
j'épouse un homme je me suis pas occupé
de la situation qu'il avait j'ai pas
épousé une situation c'est tout mais
quand même la situation d'une femme de
roulant c'est un peu spéciale
c'est un peu une vie de pas de solitude
et d'attente on attend toujours par le
fait
on attend pas au même sœurs que les
autres si vous voulez on reste souvent
seul
on fait la solitude c'est pas triste
c'est pas forcément triste
quand votre mari dans 4 ans sera la
retraite ce que vous avez l'impression
que vous le retrouverez un peu j'espère
qu'on se quittera pas du tout plus du
tout
vous attendez ce moment un peu avec
impatience
j'y pense et puis
un moment pour finir il y a un moment
pour commencer
faut bien penser qu'un jour
la retraite arrivera
le travail par lui-même n'est pas
difficile mais il faut une connaissance
de la ligne absolument parfaite
c'est à dire en plein brouillard on ne
boit pas 50 mètres et bien il faut
savoir si
[Musique]
toujours se rappeler à la réalité
toujours penser à ce qu'on est
on a pas tellement le temps de s'évader
[Musique]
je me suis rendu compte tout au long de
mon existence et
il m'avait quand même manqué quelque
chose sur le plan de la culture sur le
plan de l'instruction sur les j'ai
souhaité que mes enfants aillent à
l'école plus longtemps que j'y suis allé
et l'école est pour moi la base de tout
[Musique]
dis-moi Pascal que j'avais vu envie
d'être cheminée d'être roulant ah non
pas du tout
dis-moi pourquoi
parce que ça
d'abord ça c'est un métier technique
c'est un intéresse pas du tout
il y a pas assez de personnalité dans la
s'exprimer je sais pas
c'est comme c'est tout à fait en dehors
de mes aspirations parce que tu as été
fier parce qu'à un jour peut-être le
fils d'un roulant ou d'un cheminot
[Musique]
non ça m'est jamais arrivé
non
si tu veux être le fils d'un pilote d'un
commandant de bord de Boeing
bon ça aurait été la même chose je pense
c'est sûr
[Musique]
à quel âge vous êtes entré à la SNCF
ah ça je m'en souviens
c'était le 15 septembre 1942
aussi
je vais mettre
je me souviens j'avais me percher sur un
mur pour pouvoir passer les trains sur
la ligne du Mont d'Or
j'étais fasciné par les machines à
vapeur
s
j'ai toujours vécu dans ce milieu-là
dans cette boîte de chaussures là j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup de
souvenirs
mais c'est la boîte à souvenir un peu
pêle-mêle mais enfin
j'ai retrouvé des photos oui c'est vrai
photo de cette époque je n'ai pas
beaucoup et puis
de photos
2 4 6 7 on était une promotion de 10
apprentis
[Musique]
oui beaucoup de camarades
on sentait qu'on était groupé dans le
même
dans la même idée
ça c'était une 150 mais t'es perchée
complètement sur la sur la boîte à fumée
[Musique]
qui sont précieux quand même
il s'est passé dans cette dans cette
période
beaucoup de choses exceptionnelles
j'en ai beaucoup de souvenirs
des choses que j'oublierai jamais
d'une part parce que
le souvenir d'entrer dans la vie
professionnelle d'abord
quitter l'école et puis être confronté
avec des hommes quoi 15 ans on s'en
souvient toujours
et puis après le contexte de la guerre
bien sûr
j'ai connu le dépôt occupé par les
Allemands
les Allemands étaient à vos côtés
c'est la résistance
c'est une région où la résistance a été
particulièrement active
ça c'était la guerre avec toutes ses
conséquences
pour une seule elles ont été tragiques
et en particulier pour les cheminots
beaucoup de souvenir
[Musique]
pour la première fois depuis 30 ans
Robert fournigaud est revenu à Ussel à
la recherche de sa jeunesse
[Musique]
une page est tournée le TGV le turbo
train à grande vitesse dans le prototype
est actuellement en essai roulera demain
à des vitesses supérieures à 300 km/h le
rail n'est pas mort
le TGV je suis persuadé que c'est le
chemin de fer de l'avenir
pour moi c'est fini mais j'aurais eu
quelques années devant moi j'aurais aimé
conduire le TGV bien sûr
en 2000 c'est pas loin ça me semble loin
il est bien possible que l'homme je dis
pas que l'homme disparaîtra je peux pas
dire si c'est bien ou c'est mal ce sera
c'est la rançon du progrès ça c'est
maintenant est-ce que l'homme sera plus
heureux je sais pas
on peut tout envisager
[Musique]